formula one comes to Las Vegas in
November now this is going to be a huge
event requiring a really big effort to
get the racetrack of course in place but
what will it look like when it's done it
turns out you don't need to be in real
life to experience the Grand Prix right
now good day Las Vegas anchor John
langler explains why you just need to be
a gamer
one of the things you may not know about
me is I'm a bit of a racing nerd
maybe it's obvious either way it turns
out there is a way to drive the Las
Vegas F1 track right here at home so
here we are we're in a game called Seto
Corsa I've got the Las Vegas track here
I've got just a Mazda Miata okay here we
are we are in the car virtual car now
this is the pits which is the area
that's under construction right now look
at the stands I mean this is what it's
going to look like at night during the
race you can see the grand synth on the
right hand on the left-hand side but
this is in real life Koval this is a
street now the track turns off
and goes behind the MSG sphere so now
we're off from behind the msg's view now
we're on sands and we're going to make a
left on the Las Vegas Boulevard
there's The Phoenician and the Palazzo
on the left again you can see the
grandstands this is what's being repaved
right now there you can see the Mirage
you see the love sign you just saw we're
gonna go by uh Caesar's Palace so
there's the wall there's the fencing
there's the Sands all of this has to be
built that is an enormous amount of work
I think I could probably do a faster
time than that if I wanted to but I
think it'd be cooler too
do a simulation in an F1 car
see what that's like
that is cool you can see the sphere
there in the background there thanks
John for that for more on John's trip
into the world of Las Vegas Sim racing
head to 8newsnow.com and tune into Good
Day Las Vegas this week as John climbs
behind the virtual wheel of an F1 car to
take on the best in the world